Religion plays a very significant role
because
what is most important to me about
religion is I think it is the only
secure basis for ethical and moral
behavior and I think that as religion
decay is ethics and morality,
the k dramatically,
and I think that often happens in
history with material prosperity in,
with lack of danger of generally
speaking.
And I think that's happening again.
So I look to not too doctrinaire
religion.
I'm not,
I'm not religious in a doctrinaire
fashion.
Uh,
and the protestantism in the Christian
church gave us that.
So I read the Bible and the religious
classics and I think of what they mean
to me and what I think they should mean
to other people.
And it plays a huge role in my life in
that regard.